we're in Mexico and we had to stop by
Starbucks because there are three cool
drinks that we found and we're gonna try
it my go-to drink for Starbucks is
usually like a nice try iced vanilla
latte just a regular latte oh I like
expresso frappuccinos recently I've just
been having a lot of cold brew so it's
gonna be interesting how different and
sugary no excellent
I never get the super sugary drinks just
looking at it's just a little bit yeah
that's a lot it has some like
yeah chocolate chunks some chocolate
dust oh wow it's intense that's really
good they're really not something I
would order on my own more than a couple
sips and ice is too much definitely a
bigger punch than just like caramel
frappe I like it Wow I would get a sugar
high from this and the coffee was
stronger than I expected I would get
this I've never had Mexican hot
chocolate eclair i always ordered hot
chocolates from starbucks so I'm pretty
excited for this one but so what's the
difference between hot chocolate in the
US and Mexican hot chocolate there's
like a very specific brand of chocolate
that Juanita it's just like a little bar
of chocolate you put in a pot and then
there's like a little tool that you use
think it makes it nice and frothy
well ooh this is great yeah I feel like
it should be wrapped in a blanket in
front of the fire smells very
heartwarming it is like Christmas Day
there's something
besides the cinnamon nutmeg kind of like
feel I would always have this like
during Christmas yeah I can see as a
Christmas tree totally this is a mango
frappe doesn't smell like mango I'm
nervous about this one it looks like
pumpkin this will be interesting
mmm oh that's refreshing that's actually
really good sweet not really a fan of
sour mangles in general I love sour
stuff so that's probably why I like it I
think this is like the equivalent of
like a berry refresher as far whoa it's
definitely like towards the Mexican
flavor Mexican Starbucks this was by far
my favorite I have to say the hot
chocolate was my favorite so like this
out there so like holiday cheer this
impressed me because it was fresher a
bit more sour
I love the caja Frappuccino is very
intense summer fall and winter like this
covers your whole year I love
[Music]
[Music]